I was asked at school if I wanted to participate
with the skills competitions
I first participated in the skills the finance
and I eventually finished first
then I was allowed to go to the euro skills in poling thanks
I trained there for about 300 hours
occasionally then
it was a bit difficult
just as heavy that you thought I don't feel like it anymore
I am completely done with it
but those were
wim and Richard
who guided me with the training
it peppered me 1 bit
and then I got motivation again
to train through
the game actually went great
was nicely on schedule
and started with the gold medal
it hasn't just brought me things
in the field of welding
but also certainly in the social field
and just the development of myself as a person